في حين أن الاضطرابات في روسيا ربما
ألقت بظلالها على الحرب في أوكرانيا، إلا أن
الصراع المميت هناك مستمر بضربة
صاروخية على مدينة
كروماتوسك الشرقية، ويقول الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي إن أربعة أشخاص على الأقل
قتلوا وأصيب العشرات عندما أطلق
صاروخ روسي واحد على الأقل.  ضرب
مطعمًا مزدحمًا في منطقة وسط المدينة،
وفي هذه الساعة تواصل فرق الإنقاذ
البحث عن ناجين. روسيا
متهمة باستهداف
منطقة مدنية عمدًا. يقول الرئيس الأوكراني إنه
يجب محاسبتهم،
كل عمل إرهابي من هذا القبيل يثبت
لنا ولنا مرارًا وتكرارًا.  للعالم أجمع
أن روسيا تستحق شيئًا واحدًا فقط
نتيجة لكل ما فعلته من
هزيمة ومحاكمة عادلة وقانونية
لجميع القتلة والإرهابيين الروس
في هذه الأثناء على خط المواجهة،
ويبدو أن القوات الأوكرانية تتقدم
مستفيدة من انقسام روسيا خلال فترة التركيز.
التمرد الذي انتهى الآن بن ويدمان من سي إن إن
لديه المزيد حول البحث عن
ناجين في كرافاتورسك
دمار تام
صاروخان ضربا كراماتورسك في
شرق أوكرانيا ضرب أحدهما
وسط المدينة وقعت الضربة في
تمام الساعة 7:32 مساءً لا
نعرف ما هي  لقد كان هو الذي ضرب ولكن
من الواضح أنه كان صاروخًا كبيرًا جدًا بالنظر إلى
مستوى الضرر هنا الآن
خلفي مباشرة كان هناك مطعم مشهور جدًا
وبالنظر إلى وقت الضربة، فمن
المحتمل أن يكون هناك العديد من الأشخاص داخل المطعم
يقول أحد الشهود داخل المطعم إنه
كان  كان مكتظًا بالناس عندما
سقط الصاروخ، ورأى رجال الإنقاذ يسحبون عشرات
الأشخاص من
ألواح الخرسانة المنهارة في
وسط المطعم،
ويواصل المسعفون ورجال الإطفاء
سحب الناس بعد ساعات من الهجوم
وإزالة السيارات المتضررة من
الشوارع المحيطة لتمهيد الطريق
لمزيد من الإنقاذ.  العمل صافرات الإنذار بالغارة الجوية تحذر
من غارة أخرى مما أدى إلى توقف عمليات البحث
والإنقاذ والتحرك بين الحشود بحثًا
عن أحبائهم، أدى الانفجار إلى سقوط هذه
المرأة من قدميها.
كنت في منتصف شقتي ثم
سمعت انفجارًا مفاجئًا
وسقطت قدمي من على الأرض.  الموجة
تحطمت النوافذ في
الطابق الأول، كنت خائفًا جدًا،
كرامر تورسك ليس بعيدًا عن الخطوط الأمامية
حيث تستمر الحرب على روسيا في
ضرب أهداف تبدو عشوائية
والمدنيون يدفعون الثمن النهائي،
أريد فقط السلام للجميع، السلام